bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue ravi de vous retrouver pour notre
rendez vous quotidien dans son nouveau
format
grâce aux merveilles de la technologie
nous sommes en direct avec laurent
tailhade bonsoir charles laurence oms
laguian on sera tous vous êtes la
présidente du parti républicain
solidariste engagé de longue date en
faveur de la laïcité et vous est aussi
l'auteur c'est votre dernier livre de
être une femme en 2020 publié aux
éditions michalon bonsoir gabriel fut l
on signale rouquette son chef du site
boulevard voltaire vous collaborez par
ailleurs à l'hebdomadaire famille
chrétienne est votre dernier livre
enraciné point d'exclamation nous sommes
tous d héritier a été publiée aux
éditions artège olivier babeau et là
aussi bon soir olivier bonfond guillaume
économiste président fondateur du think
tank libéral l'institut sapiens et
auteur d'un éloge de l'hypocrisie publié
aux éditions du cerf et bonsoir adrien
maeght tout on s'engueule on sera tous
politiques à marianne marianne qui
publie cette semaine une couverture peut
être un peu stigmatisante je ne sais pas
en tout cas vous y dénoncer les
profiteurs ceux qui se gavent d'argent
public qui colle la pression aux
salariés et qui rafle des entreprises
pour une bouchée de pain
et bien ce soir n'ont pas parlé des
profiteurs mais deux sujets qui n'ont
absolument rien à voir
le premier d'entre eux ce sont les
propositions de la convention climat la
convention climat vous avez ce sont ces
150 français tirés au sort et chargé de
faire donc des propositions pour lutter
contre les gaz à effet de serre et le
réchauffement climatique
c'est 150 propositions sont assez
radical nous en avons sélectionné
quelques unes si vous ne connaissez pas
encore par exemple il ya la vitesse sur
l'autoroute qui serait limitée à 110 km
heure
et l'année prochaine et puis il ya la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments qui
serait obligatoire d'ici 2040 de tous
les bâtiments
il faudrait aussi qu'on mange moins de
viande qu'on boive moins de lait et puis
il ya aussi dans la batterie de mesures
préconisées par cette convention la
suppression des zones commerciales
alors qu'est ce que ça va devenir tout
ça va le pression dans le public a dit
qu' il allait les prendre très au
sérieux ces différentes mesures
alors c'est vrai que c'était avant de
les connaître peut-être at-il changé
d'avis depuis je ne sais pas en tout cas
il a dit qu'il pourrait envisager ou
bien de les faire passer dans une loi
qui leur donnerait donc force
contraignante et réglementaires ou bien
peut être un référendum
peut-être un référendum avec plusieurs
questions c'est l'une des l'un des
projets qui seraient envisagées mais on
va se concentrer ce soir sur les mesures
elle même et puis aussi sur la
représentativité sur la légitimité de
cette convention climat je le disais
constitué de france est tiré au sort
regardez ce commentaire assez lapidaire
de csg eux c'est sur lefigaro.fr il nous
dit en quoi 150 du bus devraient nous
imposer leur vision
ça c'est un point de vue exprimé avant
l'émission mais bien sûr vous allez
continuer à nous faire part de vos
opinions sur lefigaro.fr ou sur twitter
hashtag moins de vue est-ce qu'ils sont
légitimes adrien matos et 150 français
qui n'ont été élus par personne et qui
ne doivent leur leur place kosor qui les
a désignés sont ils légitimes pour
proposer des mesures aussi radicales
alors pour proposer à priori tout le
monde est à peu près légitime moi
effectivement j'ai pas de de goût
particulier pour ce principe qui
consiste à sélectionner des jambes
car voilà par appel il faut préciser
évidemment que ces 150 personnes ont
rencontré des scientifiques que
rencontrer tout ce qui se fait de
spécialistes en france pour pour
élaborer leurs propositions à mon avis
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il ya l'idée
du référendum qui dans l'air c'est pour
donner justement une légitimité à ces
propositions
ensuite alors viendra peut-être ensuite
sur le débat sur le fond mais moi
personnellement je ne suis pas du tout
choquée par ces propositions puisque si
on introduit un peu de deux chiffres de
données sur sur la situation
voilà il ya un consensus scientifique
quasiment totale sur l'augmentation de
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre et
donc le réchauffement climatique
il ya également sur le fait que cette
augmentation est due à l'activité
humaine et il ya un autre problème en
matière d'environnement qui passe
présente des ressources je donne juste
un chiffre comme ça pour qu'on puisse se
rend compte depuis 500 ans la population
mondiale a été multipliée par 14
or la consommation d'énergie et les x
115 et si la planète entière vivait avec
le mode de vie d'un français moyen
il faudrait 2 cette planète pour sous
pour supporter ce mode de vie donc
l'idée on élit c'est quand même de
prendre des mesures pour éviter
justement que que là que le
réchauffement climatique qui vient que
l'épuisement des énergies qui vient ne
nous oblige à être aux situations peu
darwinienne où ce serait vraiment les
plus pauvres qui seraient les victimes
de cela et on a dit voilà il faut
prendre des mesures qui peuvent sembler
radical aujourd'hui mais qui pourrait
être salvatrice pour préserver
l'humanité
gabriel cluzel est ce que vous êtes
prêtes à rouler moins vite sur
l'autoroute et peut-être à manger - dia
ourthe pour laisser une une planète
viable à nos enfants
alors les je crois qu'en toute chose il
faut équilibre
alors je veux dire quelque chose
d'absolument iconoclaste et pourtant et
qui est bien réel je ne crois pas qu'il
ya un consensus absolu sur la question
du climat même si je sais qu'aujourd'hui
c'est est diabolisé de dire cela mais je
ne crois je ne le crois pas et je crois
qu'on a le droit d'en parler comme de
tous les sujets et et que ça il faut il
faut jamais l'oublier
et puis je ne crois pas non plus qu un
consensus sur les sur les solutions
alors par exemple on va vers une
réduction de la vitesse sur l'autoroute
je vous rappelle qu'il ya quelques temps
pour d'autres raisons on avait envie
d'aller de réduire la vitesse sur les
nationales ça s'est révélé être dans la
pratique une catastrophe cat sur les
belles théories et puis dans la pratique
c'est sa semelle pour le mode de vie des
gens absolument catastrophique
et puis me semble utile pour ce que j'en
ai vu moi je suis pas scientifique donc
je n'ai encore jeu je ne pose pas de
jugement définitif je dis simplement
qu'on a le droit d'en parler
allez encore - climatologues mais il me
semble que il avait été remarqué au
moment du confinement que finalement la
fin de la circulation dans paris n'avait
pas amélioré tant que cela les
conditions la pollution voilà encore une
fois je veux pas dire de bêtises mais il
ne s'en tient pas compte un statut alors
toutes ces mesures me semble manquer
comment dire un peu de 2,2 d'équilibré
de bon sens je pense par ailleurs par
exemple à cette décision qui pourrait
faire l'objet avant d'être prise d'un
référendum de procéder à une à une
isolation des bâtiments mais je me dis
queen du patrimoine et d'un certain
nombre de bâtiments très anciens et que
l'eau qui vont se retrouver et
extrêmement pénalisées par cette mesure
je me demande si on a bien envisagé
toutes ces questions là la consommation
de viande derrière il ya des filiales
entière qu'il faudrait pas fasciné par
cela donc et puis je ne voudrais pas que
cette question climatique aubert toutes
les autres il me semble que les derniers
jours nous ont montré qu'il y avait un
certain nombre de priorités
alors moi je suis pourquoi pas faire des
référendums des faisons donc peut-être
préférentiellement sur des sujets comme
la santé le communautarisme la sécurité
qui me semble-t-il occupe plus l'esprit
des français
laurent tailhade est ce que le caractère
un peu coercitif de toutes ces mesures
vous inquiète ou est-ce que ça vous
paraît justifiée compte tenu de
l'urgence climatique même si celle-ci
gabriel plus elle le rappelait ne fait
pas forcément l'unanimité mais je pense
que si on se positionner uniquement sur
la question de l'urgence climatique des
gens de tout faux parce que on a une
responsabilité vis-à-vis des générations
futures qui n'est pas que climatique qui
aussi transmettre une terre sur laquelle
ils vont pouvoir cultiver des légumes
sains sur laquelle ils vont pouvoir
faire paître certain nombre de points de
troupeaux et moi ce qui me gêne c'est
d'un côté la grille bashing de de ce
compte rendu
il ya des territoires entiers qui vivent
de l'agriculture je parle notamment de
mon territoire un compte à l'eau si
demain il ya plus d'élevage et puis
d'agriculture c'est un territoire qui
est mort donc on ne peut pas faire ce
genre et d'agri bashing à mon sens
l'autre chose c'est que cette convention
pour moi elle s'avance sur des des
revendications qui sont finalement une
accumulation de mesures mais on n'est
pas dans une modification plus radicale
de nos modes de fonctionnement et c'est
ça qui m'inquiète le plus parce que si
on veut effectivement incité les gens à
changer de modèle il faut déjà que
modèle en lui-même accepte de se
réformer en l'occurrence combat on le
voit bien ce sont des mesures
additionnées les unes aux autres mais
n'y a pas de logique structurelle qui
semble s'imposer et la logique
structurelle elle commence d'abord par
un système fiscal qui est adapté la
réforme je veux pas dire la création de
nouveaux impôts parce que ça c'est les
anciennes méthodes
et c'est pas du tout comme ça que je
longtemps mais c'est effectivement
interroger nos échanges internationaux
relocaliser et tout ça pour l'instant ce
n'est pas abordée alors à priori ça
faisait pas partie non plus des mesures
qui était envisagé maintenant sur la
légitimité de cette organisation
il y en a à mon sens aucune la
république française
elle s'appuie sur des une constitution
cet instant cette constitution prévoit
des institutions ces institutions c'est
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat qui
légifère pour le peuple par mandat du
peuple et en l'occurrence ces personnes
au mandat d'un état et non pas du peuple
et donc aujourd'hui vouloir imposer ce
genre de décision et de propositions qui
n'émane pas de personnes qui sont
mandataires du peuple je trouve ça très
dangereux après si on veut faire passer
ses propositions qui me semble pour
certaines de kim donc ils vont être très
probablement totalement impopulaire
quand on le met à mon avis le référendum
risque d'être très défavorable à
emmanuel macron ça serait dommage qu'ils
finissent mal à cause de ça on va on va
y revenir je vais bien sûr passer la
parole à olivier babeau mais je voudrais
d'abord vous la donner à vous chers
internautes
d'abord à babineau qui est toujours
fidèle au poste qui se pose lui aussi la
question de la légitimité de ce panel et
du référendum et d'un référendum qui
pourrait tourner en vote sanction contre
emmanuel macron si abonde dans le sens
de gabriel cluzel pour nous dire que les
bâtiments anciens ne sont pas et ne
pourront jamais être aux normes qu'il
faudra les rasés et les reconstruire
et puis nicole 06 qui nous dit comme
d'habitude cela se traduira par des
interdictions des punitions et sûrement
des taxes ou impôts malheureusement chez
nicole ça faisait un peu partie des
idées de la convention qui dit qu'elle
n'a pas eu le temps en tout cas ces
responsables disent qu'ils n'ont pas eu
le temps de prévoir le côté recettes de
ce plan parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
dépenses supplémentaires mais qu' il
serait pas hostile
en tout cas pour un certain nombre de
représentants de cette instance à une
forme dit sf climatique
olivier babeau faire des propositions
c'est un peu votre métier puisque vous
êtes le patron d'un think tank
même si ce n'est pas lui qui était à la
manoeuvre là il faut quand même rappeler
qu' il y avait des citoyens tirés au
sort mais qui avaient aussi
les gens de chez terra nova qui est un
autre signe fort bon on va dire de
sensibilité plutôt socialiste qui était
là dans le comité de gouvernance de
cette convention
mais ma question était qu'est ce que
vous pensez de du de la copie remise au
président de la république elle note lui
donnez-vous non moi je mais
malheureusement il faudrait pouvoir
mettre des notes négatives 1 la
convention citoyenne ça s'annonçait
comme une extraordinaire usine à
produire des impôts des taxes des
mesures liberticides et autres mesures
néo soviéto id repeinte en vert et cette
production a dépassé toutes les
espérances pour ce qu'il faut vraiment
s'en féliciter c'est extraordinaire non
depuis le début c'était gelé dit à
plusieurs reprises c'était absurde et
dangereux et ça a révélé exactement ce
qu'il ce que ce qui s'annonce est un
dangereux évidemment pour le système
représentatif dont ça accroît le manque
de légitimité
et là la compréhension de la part des
gens absurde aussi parce qu évidemment
ces gens au pire bien au mieux c'est une
collection d'opinion et on se souvient
que idiot ça vient du grec ça veut dire
le simple la simple personne le bassin
est idiot tessin donc on s'en souvient
des spas et donc a pas de raison que ce
soit plus intéressant que intérêts de
son côté chose et on a une ère où les
opinions dissidentes pas je vous
interromps un instant mais dans
l'antiquité on tirait au sort certain
nombre de citoyens pour donner leur avis
c'est vrai parfois dire pour être juge
comme c'était le cas pour kraft un
moment donné mais le problème de
démocratie est la force de la démocratie
athénienne c'est qu'elle avait un peuple
et qu'il était à peu près si je me
trompe pas 5000 citoyens seulement est
donc évidemment c'était plus facile
non là alors au pire au pire c'est
uniquement la voix de son maître alors
la voix des minorités agissantes qu'on
réussit à se glisser eu la voix de
l'état qui essayent de 10 m les mesures
qu'il avait envie de faire passer est
effectivement on n'est quand même pas
déçu on parle par le résultat on a tous
c'est le concours lépine de la mesure
liberticide
c'est une répétition tous les pontes au
sein de toutes les idées reçues de tous
les trucs inapplicable
les trucs qui ferait de la france en
quelques années un pays du quart du
cinquième au monde 1 avec une vingtaine
à pigny applicabilité absolument totale
on est complètement consternés du degré
de conneries absolue de trucs qui sont
balancés et moi je suis consterné parce
que le président macro qui pourtant
semble avoir une tête bien faite
en plus d'être bien pleines avait pu
prévoir ce genre de choses et il sait
quasiment engagé à traduire avec des
mécanismes qu'on a dans la constitution
à traduire en obligations pour
l'ensemble de la société
c'est délire absolu je suis absolument
consterné à tous comment est-ce que deux
esprits aussi éclairé qu'olivier babou
et vous-même peuvent avoir des opinions
aussi différente et j'ai pas parlé de
problèmes climatiques un jeu n'y pas de
problème climatique du tout c'est pas la
question
réputé l'éducation beaucoup de gens ont
peur des avis différents que tu en étant
informés sur le sujet après voilà moi je
j'ai je partage les réserves sur le mode
de désignation de ces personnes
et voilà le processus alors ceci dit bon
je ne peux pas je me permets modestement
de rappeler que 6,6 sur le comment dire
sur le constat du réchauffement
climatique et du fait que notre mode de
vie actuel est incompatible avec la
préservation de l'écosystème et voilà
d'une planète à l'état par les humains
il y à là désolé de le rappeler il ya un
consensus total des scientifiques qui
travaillent sur le sujet il ya peut-être
deux ou trois 36 heures qui émettent des
avis différents mais c'est pas du tout
un débat à 50 50 sur le sujet ensuite on
peut débattre des solutions
effectivement à mettre en place pour
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique mais le fêter leur jeu
j'entends bien l'argument liberticide
mais force est de constater que sans
forcément mettre en place une nouvelle
l'urss comme comme le craignait il est
pas beau il ya il y aura forcément une
dose de contrainte c'est ça me paraît
inévitable
à
à moyen terme de limiter le mode de vie
notamment de nos concitoyens qui sont le
mode de vie le plus comment dire qu'il
ya le plus d impact négatif sur
l'activité et sur le climat donc voilà
ça me paraît nécessaire sans forcément
mettre tout le monde dans des prisons ou
des goulags
je pense qu'il faut être rationnel en
toute chose et voilà prendre les
décisions qui s'imposent d'ailleurs je
joue juste un dernier petit élément en
terme de nos rationalité bah justement
la fermeture récente et qui va se
prolonger de la centrale nucléaire de
fessenheim est un non sens absolu
puisque grâce à l'énergie nucléaire la
france
la france a disposé de la de l'énergie
une des moins carboné d'europe alors
j'en reviens à nos internautes qui
débattent entre eux et c'est une très
bonne chose
on vous pose la question sur twitter
selon vous ces 150 propositions vont
elles trop loin c'est oui oui à près de
64%
c'est une majorité très forte mais c'est
pas non plus c'est pas non plus
complètement unilatérale et puis cette
réaction de le pen en show c'est un
pseudonyme qu on le précise qui nous dit
at on réellement compris l'enjeu
non car on en est encore aux jeux
politiciens désuet on parle de la vie
sur terre et certains y opposent leur
confort et leur finance
et puis cette réaction de marie lucas ce
qui nous dit c'est vraiment pathétique
cette infantilisation de la chose
publique avec des panels qui décide de
tout et de rien c'est le syndrome tv
réalité
laurent tailhade parlé de l'importance
de continuer à faire vivre un certain
nombre de territoires et notamment par
la filière agricole la filière de
production vous city le cantal
département cher à mon corps est celui
de gabriel cluzel d'ailleurs qui n'est
pas très loin dans l'aveyron mais
peut-être qu'il ya une proposition qui
va vous séduire alors chère laurence
c'est celle consistant à interdire les
zones commerciales
écoutez ce témoignage de mathilde himer
c'est l'une des responsables du comité
de gouvernance c'est comme ça qu'on dit
de cette convention citoyenne
quand on dit on interdit les zones
commerciales tas pour le plaisir c'est
que derrière ça te permet quoi de
redonner vie au petit commerce dans les
villes et villages qui aujourd'hui sont
entre guillemets un peu foutu en tout
cas des wc et qui politiquement
d'ailleurs se traduisent par une montée
de l'abstention du populisme donc c'est
je pense que ça dessine un monde qui est
mieux vivre faut pas s'arrêter
uniquement à aux interdictions et
obligations mais de regarder pourquoi
est ce qu'on fait
laurent tailhade c'est pas une mauvaise
idée de fermer les méga centres
commerciaux qui tue le petit commerce
je pense qu'il faut quand même regarder
les choses à leurs origines comment on
fonde une zone d'activité commerciale ce
sont des élus locaux ce sont des
départements qui se mettent d'accord et
qui donne ensuite les agréments de
d'ouverture de zones d'activités
commerciales donc le premier responsable
du développement de ces zones
d'activités qui ont détruit les
centres-villes et donc le commerce de
proximité et beaucoup aussi de
d'entreprise ce sont les élus locaux
je vous donne un exemple tout simple à
aurillac où il ya une zone commerciale
très dense qui s'est développée on a un
centre ville qui est totalement détruit
des commerçants qui ne peuvent pas
transmettre leur leur boutique leur
patrimoine de ce fait et des millions
d'euros qui sont déversés en actions
coeur de ville sans aucun résultat
donc le problème effectivement il est là
maintenant parler des autres d'activités
commerciales comme étant les interdire
en se disant que c'est comme ça qu'on va
agir pour l'environnement pardonnez moi
mais je pense que on va surtout agir sur
la relocalisation sur des emplois
peut-être plus pérenne et des emplois
qui seront moins précaire en parallèle
dans les propositions qui ont été faites
moi il ya des choses qui me semble
complètement aberrante passer de 130 à
110 km heure c'est très intéressant sauf
qu'aujourd'hui on est en train de
rénover notre parc automobile qui
théoriquement doit être moins polluants
après on peut reparler des modes de
production des voitures électriques et
des matériaux qui sont utilisés dès
qu'ils vont surtout être être récoltés à
l'autre côté du monde donc c'est
complètement stupide parler aussi de
gégé noter qu est ce que j'ai noté
d'autrui l'aréna parce que l'on va
beaucoup de propositions mais qui me
semble complètement aberrante c'est la
rénovation effectivement de l'habitat je
suis pour effectivement la rénovation de
l'habitat je trouve que c'est une très
bonne chose mais l affaire de la façon
contraignante que j'ai entendu c'est à
dire d'aller surtaxés la taxe foncière
des gens qui ne rêve 9 pas leur habitat
la plupart du temps quand on rénove pas
son habitat c'est qu'on en a juste pas
les moyens parce qu'évidemment ceux qui
en ont les moyens le fond puisque ça
permet de faire des économies d'énergie
et donc de dépenser moins d'argent dans
son chauffage dans son
actrice it et en règle générale donc il
faut arrêter de prendre les gens pour
des vaches à lait s'il ne remplace pas
leur chaudière s'ils ne veulent pas leur
habitation c'est tout simplement qu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens ils ont besoin
d'être accompagnés pour ça et je pense
que la première des priorités ça serait
quand même que l'état prenne ses
responsabilités en terme de rénovation
urbaine et que lui-même face rénové
notamment les parcs de logements sociaux
parce que la priorité c'est quand même
de faire en sorte que les personnes qui
ont le moins de moyens
puis se chauffer et vivre dignement sans
avoir à être surtaxés par des factures
d'edf qui sont scandaleuses merci cher
laurent sayède ce sera le mot de la fin
en tout cas sur ce sujet puisque je
propose d'en aborder à un autre on ne
part